despite what are your general rules for
raising money for films I mean what do
you advise your NYU students when the
subject comes up what kind of guidance
do you provide them well I've been
teaching in my youth the past 15 years
and the issue is whether you're in film
school or not film school where you get
to - shoot where you get the money - for
completion to finish your film I tell
people you just have to be inventive and
you gotta look under every nook and
cranny to get it done there's not
there's not there's nothing I could tell
somebody that's gonna be like the golden
trail and you're gonna find a pot of
gold you know at the end is that's just
not the way this industry works so
there's no set roadmap but I'm wondering
is there a certain mindset
are there certain characteristics
whether they're temperament whatever
that you tell someone well I think that
when you want to mean looking for money
and you have to have that be tough to
tough-as-nails and not be deterred by
knows all it takes that one person at
one grant that one scholarship you know
money can show
and fall out of sky sometimes I mean
that's not that something that that you
had to wait for and what am i one of my
own most favorite quotes is by Brooklyn
Dodger owner Branch Rickey who signed
Jackie Robinson and the code assists
luck is a residue of design so if you
working in busting your ass you better
chance of luck smiling down upon you but
are you just chilling and not extend any
injury excuse not extending any energy
don't get it from go
you're not we're not seeing that elbow
grease we're not seeing initiative when
I seen that blood sweat tears very
rarely will you find yourself in a lucky
situation
speaking of way but you can't depend on
luck though you can't depend on luck
I've been very lucky be honest when I
decided when we filmmaking there was
only one african-american director work
in Hollywood his name was Michael
Schultz director in my favorite films
Cooley aye
and so when I would tell my
african-american friends you know
they're like black people
they let black people direct films and
so I never ever thought about the odds
a lot of times you think about stuff
like that it could be a self-inflicted
paralysis but I knew I wanted to do and
that was committed that through hard
work God willing
something will break my way and it
happened out of the 50 plus movies
you've directed and produced which was
the hardest to find financing for well I
would definitely have to say the first
one she's gonna have it which costs
$175,000 because that was my debut film
as far as a feature film as future films
go and people think that I did that film
right at the film school there was a
four year period between me finishing in
weiu and she's gonna have it coming out
so it was not
like that and then another one would be
a Malcolm X we ran out of money they had
to go get some money - does it ever get
easier what's easy that's easy I mean it
was easy you know I wouldn't be I
wouldn't have launched a Kickstarter
campaign it's just weird day five so
this is tough business you know you know
that's and I really and II can tell you
he's one of my students and every time
I'm here in LA he helps me but I do not
try to sugarcoat things all to my
students and there'll be a de great
disservice to them if I did that so I
let them know you know this this is no
guarantee it's gonna happen for you we
shot she's gonna have we we shot she's
gonna have it in 1985 we were doing
Kickstarter for the worst Kickstarter we
just had the technology I was making
phone calls making personal visits
writing letters so we did everything
except so she me it was social meet was
not around it do you think that people
that are already established are taking
away quote chances from the little guys
no look I understand why people might
think that but that's not the case at
all I'm bringing people to Kickstarter
never go to Kickstarter I'm talking live
people of color never at Kickstarter
who's never made a pledge
on Kickstarter so I really think that
it's a fallacy it's a misconception and
I just played out it's just playing out
wrong with the capital W that because
someone puts five dollars on my film
some who backs my film five dollars that
was five dollars that a young filmmaker
was gonna get and that logic does not
just not follow through I mean there
there's concrete evidence with what mr.
Thomas did with Veronica Mars and what
was Zach did with his film people
majority of people who backed those
things had never been on Kickstarter
before but I think those people back
films after that once they were once
they made were made the introduction to
Kickstarter so to be honest I know the
course I know that I mean look I know
you had to ask this question so it's
cool the two co-founders of Kickstarter
told me that you know Ron mr. Thomas had
flak he caught flak Zach caught flak
Zach flak and that I would get the same
so this is not a surprise at all but
this this is uh I've been hearing stuff
for the very first film she's gonna have
it was a portrayal of black women
school days I was airing dirty laundry
do the right thing would make black
people run amuck and right all across
the country when it came out I was
anti-semitic because my characters join
Moe and Josh Flatbush and mo better
blues so I just rolled with the punches
and keep going and the fact that I'm
here in my third decade making films is
concrete evidence of that I'm gonna keep
Kurosawa's 85-86
went so you know I don't go that long
but I had many many more films many many
many more stories to tell and this
little use of word on you
this little brouhaha about Spike Lee is
comes in Bogart Kickstarter and he's
taking advantage of the young
up-and-coming filmmakers is is as Mike
that's my good friend Mike Tyson once a
is ludicrous for example why would I be
teaching for the past 15 years and why
you if I have not care about young
filmmakers why would I be the artistic
director up in why you write a film
school if I not care about young
filmmakers why have I've given out over
over $20,000 in the Spike Lee production
fund they're gonna filmmakers and why
you if I not
young filmmakers so people say they want
the truth is the truth so for a
filmmaker that does have that mindset
that Oh a name is taking away from quote
our backers that'll back our little
zombie short do you think they have the
right mindset to make it in the film
business as brutal and as difficult as
it is do you think that's setting them
up with the right mindset look I
understand why they feel that way but
why they the reason they feel that way
or ill-conceived it's just not true and
they they just got to work hard to make
sure that their stuff is tight so when
people do look at their links that don't
wanna back then is it a cutthroat game
to get to your level do you think people
realize how hard that is oh I think
people realize I mean that's one of the
reasons why I mean some filmmakers have
had those feelings towards your vampire
Mars Zach Braff myself because it is a
tough business but here's the thing we
are not some pirates showing up
to rape them pillar I've been always
being more than generous with my time
and money young filmmakers and that will
continue always and if and I've told
this to Nancy and Perry who are the
cofounders of kick started that if we
make any profits I will step endowment
so that the dividends can go to young
filmmakers on Kickstarter I believe you
said in an interview with NYU that you
can't stand a lazy student right what do
you see in most independent filmmakers
however old they are
that makes them lazy and that hinders
their career well I don't want to make a
blanket statements about independent
filmmakers but I've had students who are
lazy and laziness is something I really
can't tolerate so because of laziness I
think that that speaks of a sense of
entitlement and
that's just not a good look in this
industry where you think that you were
titled to something that you didn't you
deserve something because you know
wherever you think you are it doesn't
work like that another thing I'd like to
add is that and I'm speaking about my
school a lot of people come on and why
you thinking that because you have this
degree from this prestigious prestigious
institution in Yee or USC or ef5
Columbia and the real world they don't
really give a you know if you don't
have the talent that degree doesn't mean
a thing when you come out of school you
should have your directorship of film
your deep you should have a real editor
should have a real if your screen right
should have scripts so people are people
really want to see the work you've done
is it harder to raise 25 million to make
a film or is it harder to raise 1 or 2
million for a smaller film I mean does
it are the stakes tell you what dance is
easy is hard to raise a million than 25
million why
because there's just this mindset that a
film cost million dollars there's very
little wanna see or very little bit
return of investment in a film that
small so it's almost that mind said that
kinda you get what you pay for in terms
of let's say I wouldn't say that I
understand as a prejudice against films
under million